a train wreck of a fact check
yes reuters invites hilarity by
fact-checking obvious parody telling its
readers no such luck biden doesn't
really chase the ice cream truck
so it's no secret the big guy enjoys his
ice cream that's just one of the reasons
why dr jill calls him mr softy
but
[Applause]
terrible
but as we you know as we speak he's
actually lobbying baskins and robins to
make a flavor based on little girl's
shampoo
[Applause]
although when joe says sprinkles it
means call the urologist
true the
the cold sweet treat is perfect for
cooling down after a long hot sweaty day
of aimlessly drifting around the white
house like a tumbleweed
but now reuters which claims to be a
news outlet is getting mocked online for
actually fact checking a clearly edited
video of biden getting distracted by an
ice cream truck and walking out of frame
watch the doctored video
bowser and chancellor fairby
you know thank you for joining us as
well
and for families across the country you
know the school year
that's hilarious
i i would say the footage does seem
manipulated there's no
there's no way joe can move that fast
but give him a break he's got oil cancer
the original video is from last
september when the president and
renowned pediatric neurosurgeon dr jill
biden
spoke at a middle school about the
pandemic well jill spoke to the students
he just sniffed them
but no he didn't leave because of an ice
cream truck but the edited version
somehow forced reuters to take time away
from hard hitting journalism to actually
fact check it
altered this video has been digitally
edited to include ice cream truck music
[Applause]
finally though they got a fact check
right
but if you're gullible enough to think
that's real you just might be nicole
wallace
and that's not a joke so no need to fact
check it
so let's see let's why don't we sit back
and see what the real video was like the
unedited one
ona and
mayor bowser and chancellor fairby
you know thank you for joining us as
well
and for families across the country you
know the school year
gosh it always brings this sort of mix
of emotions
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
tyrus i told you this is the greatest
segment ever
fact checking memes
i honestly feel the ice cream edit is
better
[Laughter]
what do you want hungry grandpa or
wandering grandpa president
you literally go who's got the president
where is he like
he's just
i feel like that's probably more
accurate yeah yeah every time i watch
that i'm looking for a reason why he
leaves
unless that ghost who wants to shake his
hand is back
did he just
that he just strolled off like
she was at the goodbye part
unless he has no tolerance for people
messing up during the speech because the
good doctor of pediatrics and
neurosurgery she was having a hard time
with the names yeah so he just he just
walked off i think cat our daughter
little tag on him yes
cat i think our doctored video
is actually probably true he probably
had he he probably had to go to the
bathroom why is he wearing a mask
outside standing next to his wife that's
just
weird although i mean i can kind of see
almost why they did it i mean ever since
i saw that video of him shaking the hand
when no one was there
like
how does it get how does it get crazier
than that i don't but then i realized
there's no way that he would go get ice
cream without someone telling him he's
allowed to first yeah
i felt bad for the the person next to
him because you could see them going is
that is that the president
are we supposed to get him is he allowed
to do that is he allowed to do that
larry uh
it's such a terrifying story because
where where was he going
right this is the great doctorate
reuters facts what was he doing he is
our president
i mean really it's absolutely terrifying
he's going after afghanistan gorillas
and terrorists and he can't even get
through the other one you should play
the one word she's uh she's giving a
speech and she puts her hand down and he
starts sucking her fingers yeah do you
remember that
yes that should have tipped us off i
mean the scariest part of this is he's
the only president we have yeah i mean
honestly what are we gonna do well we
might have somebody else running the
show that isn't him that's what i'm
thinking sonny is this why people don't
trust the news it's like they're they
think we're morons but they're
fact-checking memes
let me be the third person to remind
everybody that the president was shaking
hands with absolutely nobody
so
i just want to bring that up again so if
we actually believe that he was chasing
the ice cream truck it's his own fault
right yeah
it's not our
fault for believing it and on top of
that i am inclined that this will be my
conspiracy theory moment
that video was real and he was
filtering off yeah to go get some ice
cream and and that is my story and i am
sticking it's better
what do you want to tell another country
oh he's getting ice cream or he's
wandering
hey until they fact check who he was
actually shaking hands with yes this is
my story and i'm sticking with it amen
i'm there excellent go to the light joe
he was walking towards the light
terrible he was walking toward the light
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else